this video is kindly sponsored by
curiositystream the subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
hey 42 here here's a random interesting
fact for you a little over a hundred
years ago it was widely believed that
sharks were completely harmless to
humans it was thought they were
practically incapable of biting people
and that even if they did the resultant
damage would be minimal no broken bones
no severed limbs just a few puncture
marks and a bit of blood nothing a
plaster couldn't fix basically fast
forward to today and as you've probably
noticed most people are absolutely
terrified of sharks fatal shark attacks
routinely make international news and
sharks like the great white are
consistently rated amongst the most
feared animals on the planet in polls
and surveys
sharks have also played the villains in
plenty of hollywood blockbusters most
notably steven spielberg's jaws so what
exactly changed in the last hundred
years that turned sharks from harmless
critters into bloodthirsty man-eaters in
the public consciousness it's safe to
say the sharks themselves aren't doing
anything differently they've been around
in one form or another for about 450
million years
to put that insane number into
perspective sharks evolved before trees
and the reason we underestimated these
fearsome creatures for so long is
actually pretty simple
we hadn't had the chance to spend much
time with them
the kind of beach culture that we know
and love today didn't really get going
in earnest until the middle of the 19th
century and surfing a sport often
associated with shark attacks didn't
become popular in the west until the
start of the 20th century so more people
in the water over the years
inevitably meant more encounters with
sharks but there's a bit more to it than
that
because the change in public opinion
that saw sharks shift from
harmless to horrific
was by no means gradual in fact it can
be traced back to a single two week
period
in the summer of 1916.
this is the genuinely disturbing story
of the jersey manitou and the 12 days of
terror that changed our relationship
with sharks forever
now curiosity stream is the world's
first streaming service addressing our
lifelong quest to learn explore and
understand if you're into history like
me then you need to check out their
content packed history selection but
history is only a small part of their
enormous collection with content
spanning from science nature history
technology society and lifestyle
it really is the new netflix for nerds
it's hulu for history buffs and the
disney plus for the scientists in all of
us
and what's more it offers thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
from some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals and
they're adding more exciting new content
all the time i've been particularly
enjoying watching engineering the future
it's a fascinating look behind the
scenes at the mega building projects
that humankind are undergoing to propel
our planet into the future it's
interesting to hear about the challenges
with construction on such an epic scale
and how they're overcome so if you're
anything like me and you want to take
more away from the programs you're
watching then go to curiositystream.com
42 for unlimited access to the world's
top documentaries and non-fiction series
and for my lovely viewers you can use
promo code 42 and you'll save 25
off which comes out to only 14.99
a year
that's just 125 per month so click the
link in the description below or go to
curiositystream.com42
and save 25 right now did i mention
that's only 14.99 for the whole year
which is an unbelievable price for such
an incredible wealth of content
don't miss out
the first attack came in the middle of a
sweltering summer's day near the town of
beach haven a name that was about to
gain a certain sick irony the victim 28
year old charles vancent had decided to
take a refreshing pre-dinner swim in the
ocean when he felt something rough brush
up against his leg
and then
pain
excruciating reality rending pain
onlookers on the shore saw charles
shouting and waving his arms but
not a single person rushed to his aid
not that this apparent callousness had
anything to do with fear or cowardice
these days if you see a man in the ocean
screaming and flailing his arms your
internal shark alarm starts blaring
madly and you do one of two things if
you're the hero type you rush towards
the guy and try to help and if you're
everyone else you swim for the safety of
dry land as fast as your panicky
breaststroke can propel you
but in 1916 nobody had any idea that
sharks might pose a threat to humans
and so without that context a man
shouting and flailing his arms in the
ocean was probably just horsing around
still there's only so long you can watch
a man screaming immortal terror as he's
ripped apart by a shark before you
realize it probably isn't a joke and
eventually local lifeguards went to
investigate
charles was pulled from the water in a
bad state but for reasons that aren't
entirely clear he was taken to a hotel
rather than a hospital he bled out on
the front desk
in doing so he became the first and only
confirmed victim of a fatal shark attack
in u.s coastal waters in history
not that he was going to have to wait
long for company scientists were so
confident in their belief that sharks
weren't dangerous to humans at all that
in the days after the attack they
remained unconvinced that a shark was
really to blame several other creative
theories were put forward instead
including that charles had been attacked
by a family of angry sea turtles because
of this skepticism no beaches in the
area were closed in the aftermath of
charles's death and vacationers
continued to swim in the sea off the new
jersey coast as if nothing had happened
that changed five days later when the
shark came back for more in what was
probably a coincidence but possibly an
indication that the shark had a name
fetish
the second victim was another charles
charles brooder a 27 year old bellhop
who worked in a local hotel this attack
took place about 45 miles north of beach
haven in a town called spring lake
another name that was soon to take on a
different meaning because spring a leak
is exactly what charles brooder did
he was swimming 120 meters offshore when
the shark bit him in the abdomen the
power behind the attack was astonishing
literally cutting charles in half his
legs torn free from his body there was
so much blood in the water that the
woman who reported the incident to
lifeguards thought she'd seen a red
canoe capsizing unsurprisingly charles
broder was dead before he reached ashore
and it was here that scientists so sure
of themselves after the first attack
began to do a little bit of
soul-searching
no doubt a sea turtle can give you a
nasty bite but it's hard to imagine one
could tear your legs off
no matter how many times you call it a
stupid water tortoise
charles's death appeared on the front
page of the new york times and both
scientists and locals alike began to
take this new fishy threat
far more seriously with beaches along
the new jersey coast emptying and
vacation is heading home early
but this is where things started to get
a little bit weird because it turned out
that staying out of the ocean wasn't
enough to keep people safe from the
shark that was now being called the
jersey manitou you see as crazy as it
may sound the next two victims weren't
killed in the chilly waters of the
atlantic ocean but 11 miles inland don't
worry this wasn't a sharknado situation
the next attack took place in matawan
creek a tidal inlet in raritan bay where
a group of local kids were swimming in
the sunshine when one of them spotted an
old log floating in the water nearby he
pointed it out to his friends and they
swam towards it to investigate but as
they got closer they realized something
odd the lug
was coming towards them
fast the children panicked and swam for
the shore
most of them made it but 11 year old
lester stillwell was bitten in the leg
and dragged beneath the murky water of
the creek
when he didn't resurface the remaining
children ran into town screaming for
help
despite the recent attacks the locals
didn't believe for a minute that lester
had been killed by a shark that might
sound naive but there was some reason
for doubt this time first and foremost
sharks were unsurprisingly not exactly a
common occurrence in the usually fresh
water of matawan creek on top of that
lester was epileptic the town's people
suspected he'd had a seizure and that
the other children had mistaken his
thrashing for a shark attack
confident in this hypothesis several men
ran to the creek and dived right in to
search for the missing boy it was 24
year old watson fisher who found
lester's lifeless body but as he
returned to the shore carrying leicester
in his arms the shark struck again
biting watson in the fine he was badly
injured and later died in hospital in
the space of just 12 days the jersey
manitou had killed four people it almost
claimed a fifth victim half an hour
after killing lester and watson when it
took a bite out of 14 year old joseph
dunn's leg but joseph was able to escape
when his brother and a friend dragged
him to safety with fatal attacks
seemingly coming every few days and
eyewitness accounts stacking up
the initial skepticism as to whether a
shark was to blame for all this carnage
evaporated
to be replaced with what can only be
described as mass hysteria in under two
weeks sharks seem to have evolved from
harmless ocean dwellers to
indiscriminate killers that could strike
anywhere there was water the response to
the attacks was huge
every major news outlet in the u.s
picked up on the story and patrol boats
packed with armed men were dispatched up
and down the new jersey coast the
governor of new jersey began offering
bounties to be paid on delivery of dead
sharks encouraging hundreds perhaps
thousands of people to take their boats
to hunt the moneta
many more headed to matawan creek where
people lined the shores armed with
rifles nets and in some cases dynamite
only in america
the panic even reached the white house
with president woodrow wilson scheduling
a cabinet meeting to discuss the
escalating situation
some historians have suggested that the
search for the jersey man eater may just
have been the largest animal hunt in
history in the end it was a man by the
name of michael schlieser that courts
the creature
history doesn't tell us much about
michael other than the fact he had a
rather intriguing double profession
taxidermist by day
lion tamer by night
that's a cv you don't see too often
michael claimed to have almost lost his
life whilst catching the jersey manitou
which turned out to have been a juvenile
great white shark
apparently the creature had almost sunk
michael's boat before he was able to
kill it by repeatedly smashing it over
the head with a broken ore once back on
dry land the shark's belly was opened
and about seven kilograms of what was
identified as human flesh was found
inside
mercifully the attacks abruptly stopped
but whilst the immediate threat seemed
to be over it's safe to say the jersey
manitou's fearsome teeth had left
indelible indentations in the american
psyche
swimming in the ocean would never quite
feel the same again
the funny thing is as brutal and
terrifying as the events of 1916 were
sharks are wholly undeserving of this
reputation that they now have as a
result because in reality sharks pose
very little threats to humans for
starters of the close to 500 species
currently known to science
just three are on record as having been
responsible for more than 10 human
fatalities the bull shark the tiger
shark and of course the great white
though there probably should be another
species on that list the oceanic white
tip there have long been rumors of shark
feeding frenzies taking place after
disasters at sea
the sinking of the uss indianapolis an
incident that's been mentioned in jaws
is probably the most famous example
oceanic whitetips are thought to be the
species responsible in almost all of
those cases but since there's normally
nobody around to witness them we don't
have any good data on how many victims
have been claimed by them but even if we
do add the oceanic white tip to the list
of sharks with over 10 human kills under
their lateral lines
that still means over 99 of shark
species
are pretty much entirely harmless to
humans and if you do actually look at
the numbers even the four so-called
dangerous species have only been
responsible for a tiny number of human
fatalities in the grand scheme of things
on average around four people die from
shark bites each year globally which
means practically any animal that's even
remotely dangerous is far more likely to
kill you than a shark that includes the
obvious ones like snakes spiders lions
and crocodiles but it also includes
deer
cows horses dogs hippos elephants
and ants
you're over one hundred thousand times
more likely to be killed by humanity's
deadliest foe other humans than you are
to be killed by a shark now i know what
you're thinking these numbers are skewed
by the fact most of us never go anywhere
near sharks
and that's partly true
but even if you happen to be swimming or
surfing near the shore i.e the single
place on earth where you're most likely
to be bitten by a shark
you're still far more likely to die from
drowning or a heart attack than you are
from a shark bite
it's true that shark attacks are on the
rise in many parts of the world but
again that's nothing to do with the
sharks we're just spending more time in
the water and as the world's population
continues to grow and hotter
temperatures tempt more people to cool
off in the sea
we can expect that trend to continue but
hey if sunbathing naked in the serengeti
suddenly became popular we'd probably
see more fatal lion attacks too don't
get me wrong i'm not trying to say that
sharks aren't dangerous clearly they are
it's just that they aren't nearly such a
threat to humans as they're usually
portrayed to be after hundreds of
millions of people who swim in the sea
every year only a handful end up a shark
food and the irony is sharks have far
more reason to fear us than we do to
fear them after all we kill about a
hundred million of them every single
year
at the current rate it would take the
collective efforts of shark kind about
25 million years to kill that many
humans but this barrage of statistics
actually raises a kind of interesting
question if all of this is true and
sharks just have a bad reputation
what the hell happened in 1916 if an
average of four people are killed by
sharks worldwide today
when more people are spending more time
swimming in the ocean
how could four people have been killed
by a single shark in new jersey at a
time when shark attacks were practically
unheard of
well
there's a fairly short answer to that
question we have absolutely no idea the
1916 shark attacks continue to baffle
scientists to this day the pattern
frequency and distribution of the
encounters are so unusual as to be
unique
we've quite literally never seen
anything else like them anywhere in the
world in the more than 100 years since
they took place at the time it was
believed that a so-called rogue shark
was behind the attacks that is a shark
that got a taste for human flesh and
decided to try and single-handedly wipe
out our entire species and that theory
certainly fits the evidence the attacks
took place in a neat line from south to
north suggesting a single animal
cruising up the coast but there's one
small problem with this theory so far as
we know rogue sharks don't exist
in all of recorded history you can count
on one hand the number of times a single
shark is known to have attacked multiple
people in fact putting the events of
1916 to one side for a second you can
count that number of times a single
shark is known to have attacked multiple
people
on one finger it happened in egypt in
that's it and even then the incidents
happened in the same location within
minutes of each other resulting in just
one death and four injuries
very different to 1916.
when you take our own fears out of the
equation sharks are animals like any
other they eat things because that's how
they stay alive compared to plenty of
other animals commonly found in the
ocean
human beings are a fairly terrible food
source for large sharks we're bony not
particularly calorie dense and have an
annoying habit of fighting back it
simply doesn't make sense that a shark
would suddenly decide to become a strict
humanarian it would be like you deciding
that from now on you're only going to
eat twigs although the way things are
going i'll give it about five years
until that's actually a thing
great white sharks hunt by swimming
around looking for prey on the surface
when they find it they put on an
incredible burst of speed and crash into
their dinner like a torpedo hitting the
ship
often breaching the surface of the water
spectacularly in the process we don't
typically see that behavior when sharks
bite humans because for the most part
these incidents don't come about
as a result of predatory behavior sharks
are basically like toddlers they use
their mouths to explore the world around
them when they come across an object
they aren't familiar with they give it a
bit of a nibble to see what it is the
problem is when it's a six metre 2000
kilogram great white shark doing the
nibbling it's usually enough to cut a
human being in half
okay so rogue sharks aren't a thing and
the majority of so-called shark attacks
are basically just sharks being
inquisitive and making a mess in the
process
but if it wasn't a rogue shark that
killed four people and maimed another in
what was it
one theory is that the jersey man eater
never really existed and that instead
several different sharks were
responsible
the frequency and south to north pattern
of the attacks
certainly fit the idea of a single shark
but it's possible that was just a
coincidence backing this theory up is
the fact that great white sharks like
the one caught with a belly full of
human flesh in 1916 by taxidermist come
lion tamer michael schleizer can't
survive for lung in fresh water bull
sharks on the other hand can leading
some people to believe that it was a
bull shark that killed lester stillwell
and watson fisher though i should point
out that matawan creek is tidal meaning
the water there is often brackish even
quite far inland so we can't rule out a
great white entirely
whatever it was that really happened in
new jersey in 1916
there's no denying it had a monumental
impact on the way we see sharks
even today when the weight of evidence
and statistics tells us that sharks are
the least of humanity's many concerns
they're still widely misunderstood by
the public
and misrepresented by the media
maybe it's time we changed that thanks
for watching